I have to say depressingly and right let
me say this right here and now I do not
own Adobe shares I'm not a marketing
executive for Adobe but the other day I
did actually save a PowerPoint
presentation it was something like 370
megabytes in total I'd use the save as
PDF available as standard in our point
and it reduced it from 370 to all of 210
megabytes
Wow and it was a PDF and he viewed fine
I then put it through PDF right at PDF
right and of course was a paid for
option sudo printer driver and it went
from 370 megabytes to 10 megabytes which
I think says something about the
willingness to call upon compression
technologies and the expertise in
preparing good PDFs let's just backtrack
a little bit and remind ourselves of ya
famous launch of PostScript in early
1985 John Warnock Steve Jobs all that
and the example they use we've got it
here here was John amore luxe original
PostScript which when imaged and
rendered produced this supplementary
income tax form but it was too slow for
Steve Jobs to show at the launch we've
done some stuff on this if you unroll
the loops flatten the code then you can
get something that works in about 25
seconds and that's what they did now I
know many of you will say well that's a
good start but it's not enough what
about this stuff you've gone out on in
the past about lossy and lossless
compression yes obviously in PDF many of
you will know you can do lossless LZ or
else aw type compression on Tech fine is
there it's available and yes in images
you are certainly going to need to be
able to do compression of the JPEG sort
and to have it coped with by the
PostScript and indeed the PDF image
operator so compression is of the order
of the day over and Beyond abbreviating
things if this is the glimmerings of PDF
why did it take so long for PDF to
I emerge well well how long what we're
talking Hallam we're talking from 1985
when this was done and the actual
announcement of PDF and acrobatics
viewer software was late night to early
93 so we are looking at seven years
aren't we more like eight probably by
the time you're finished why did it take
so long and answer simple you had to
wait for people's desktop workstations
to become powerful enough to handle all
this the common factor between the two
is what's called the PostScript graphic
model which is magic but remember back
in 85 the only computer in the room
powerful enough to render PostScript was
the laser writer the Mac's were utterly
incapable of doing it a standard 9 inch
Mac came with 128 K just hopeless and
they were so slow as well even so
Elizabeth so there we are then you
realize that if poster it was going to
develop away from being just something
that ended up being printed out on paper
into being something renderable on a big
screen well for a star your screens got
to be capable of holding you er of
rendering us letter size or a4 sized
pages ok relate that back to a tiny 9
inch Mac screen and the answer is well
you'll have to wait for that technology
to develop and you'll have to be
prepared to pay a fortune for your
Apollo or Sun workstations for the 70
people in your print room or whatever it
is to use but gradually slowly but
surely it did come along and of course
by 1990 there was no question
PostScript had won the high-end war
completely and totally so what was their
recommended means if you were a
PostScript devotee to get across to PDF
as a first approximation and for the
sake of argument we'll say
maybe it was Microsoft Word or something
like that
here and up until now if you want high
cause the output let's use ellipses for
stuff that's in printable formats so
we'll say PS here yes you could get word
to produce PostScript you can send that
PostScript off apple laserwriter or some
other laser writer that actually have
got PostScript inside it
Adobe were making a fair bit of nice
money thank you very much
supplying proper PostScript to go into
these are writers right through to laser
setters at the very high end the new
feature now coming along was to say well
if you put this PostScript into another
piece of Adobe software called distiller
this will turn it into this new and
wonderful P D F now you've got to give
people a means of viewing it for free
the famous Acrobat but you have to pay
if you want distiller so the next
question then was yes I'm a loyal
PostScript person but that distill is
costing a fortune Adobe I'm going to
find somebody else who can do it for me
and of course there were lots and lots
of people who would do your distiller
substitute it is not easy you have got
to be able to take the most outrageously
abominable PostScript and not crash and
I remember saying to Adobe person at the
time I said well what's wrong with alts
of these clones he said they get
everything right but the thing they
can't handle is fonts what he said well
first of all you know you're gonna
license them we've got permission from
Linotype to use their stuff but you've
got to use clone fonts and then you're
in trouble do they quite match what was
there on the original and what the
intention was and indeed fonts has
always been a problem in this I once
asked Bob wolf the leader of the team
that developed PDF distill of an acrobat
reader so Bob what were your six
greatest challenges
in developing PDF and he said Dave
that's easy fonts fonts forms fonts
fonts and fonts in that order
those were my six biggest challenges so
anyway the obvious question to ask since
this is going to cost you a lot of money
is to say well look word needs to get
into this PDF form now doesn't it to go
you know be compliant why not take a
flying leap around here cut out the
middleman as it were you don't need to
go through PostScript any more word or
any other app could use a printer driver
standard printer driver type thing
except it's not really directly driving
a printers producing a PDF file well
they did in very short order they came
out with PDF writer and again
opportunity for third parties PDF writer
of course was a paid for option to get
this PDF it was not free like reader so
a lot of people said we can do a PDF
writer that's good enough and some were
better than others inevitably so to sum
up then this is the nature of the PDF
story it took a long time to get itself
established but now it really is a de
facto standard and a very very
successful one too the only big
conundrum still left and you know for
those of us those of you who've seen my
HTML video I can only come back to this
that Tim berners-lee's comment to me
about we've got to find some way to
marry exact representation and
high-quality typography with the
flexibility to reflow stuff and we're
still in a way poles apart
I mean HTML despite CSS cannot really
aspire to the same standards of
typographic excellence
PDF can and yet PDF is exact but rigid
sometimes people try and attempt to
reflow PDF and it's rarely successful is
certainly not easy so I think John
Warnock comment I just wish you would do
something about marrying these two views
of the world is yeah one of the
advantages of PDF and PostScript is you
can say draw me on my screen a line that
is exactly one inch long and it doesn't
matter whether it's a 72 dpi screen or
whether it's a piece of bromide image
that 2,000 dots per inch that same
command in either PostScript or PDF
premier line one inch long
regardless of the resolution get your
rule around it will be one inch long
HTML can't do that
every time you grown that loop it has to
say what's my loop counter at the mando
I'm on three now let me take a look at
how far I'm supposed to oh six is oh
it's three less than six yes it is
oh I think we'd better go round again I
exaggerate